ce pourrait être le carrefour de la
discorde
c'est finalement celui de la croisée des
mondes ces quelques mètres d'asphalt
concentre tous les profils tous les
ras-le-bol le gilet jaune se porte
plutôt large cette saison et si vous
faites dans la vie sans emplois
retraités de la poste
retraités fonctionnaires tous ici
partagent le café les vivres et surtout
la conviction d'avoir été floués il y a
par exemple cette maman malade en
rémission qui ne trouvent plus ni les
mots ni la force très très dur
financièrement beaucoup de galères il
avait eu une fille toute seule avec la
maladie avec tout ce qu'on nous met sur
le doigt en ce moment ben c'est pas très
bon pour le moral pour la santé pour
tous et si les retraités les demandeurs
d'emploi plus facilement mobilisable
constituent le gros des troupes
d'autres ont pris sur eux le temps de la
révolte les fonctionnaires je j'arrive à
la fin de mois chez tout seul je suis
divorcée
j'arrive pas j'ai pris sur mesure de
plongée il me restait qu'un jour et nuit
bon ben j'ai pris mon jour il me restait
et puis je serai là mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi même jusqu'à noël si je quitte
à quai car perdre mon emploi
mais je me battrai jusqu'au bout autre
point commun de ces irréductibles le
désenchantement politique
l'abstentionnisme et leur parti préféré
commentons mon mécontentement que de
façon c'est politique aujourd'hui c'est
tout ça même ce qu'ils font tous les
autres tous les partis politiques
différents et finalement bas à la fin on
apprend qu'ils mangent tous ensemble
donc voila quand il faut arrêter comme
parent était avoir été une fois les gens
pour des idiots
voilà tiendra tiendra pas le mouvement
puisse dans un réservoir de colère bien
plus inflammable que le carburant et il
laissera sûrement des séquelles